خنق وحرق فاباده جحيم بوتين كما يوصف فتح
على الاوكرانيين في اكثر من جبهه منذ
بدايه الحرب فالشمس الحارقه او قاذفات
اللهب الروسيه الثقيله تعد اقوى الاسلحه
غير النوويه في العالم واشدها تدميرا نسخه
محدثه من الرجمات الثقيله وهي اله التوس
ون اي عسكريه مجنزره ضخمه فوقها راجمه
صواريخ حراريه فتاكه هذه الصواريخ تستخدم
الوقود والاكسجين من الهواء المحيط لتوليد
انفجار عالي الحراره اي تقذف الرذاذ الجوي
لتخلق بذلك انفجارا حول الهدف وتغطيه
بمجال حراري لا يطاق نيران الشمس الحارقه
قادره على تغطيه مساحه تصل الى 40
كيلومترا مربعا بقوه نيران هائله وتطلق 24
صاروخا خلال مده زمنيه لا تتجاوز الست
ثواني وفي جميع الاتجاهات بماذا يصل سته
كيلومترات اما اعدادها للقتال فلا يتعدى
تسعين ثانيه وتنطلق بسرعه تبلغ 60
كيلومترا في الساعه هذا السلاح الخارق
يخنق ضحاياه حتى الموت ومن المستحيل
اختباء من نيرانه حتى في الخنادق فموسكو
تروج للسلاح الفريد بانه يحول الهواء الى
لهب يضيف الاهداف ويبيدها وبالفعل ليس
هناك شبيه لهذه القاذفات في ترى سنات
الغرب العسكريه لكنها لقيت ندها فالقاذفات
التي تحول الليل الى نهار من شده توهجها
ضعيفه الامكانات بمواجهه الطيران المسير
بمختلف في احجامه فالشمس الحارقه تفوقت
على جميع الاسلحه العملاقه وقهرها السلاح
الصغير
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات